ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักรีใส่แล้ว
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนเดียวเปลี่ยนทุกคน
เป็นยังไงบ้างคะ
ถามเหมือนกันเลย
เป็นยังไงบ้างครูพระก็ถามเป็นยังไงบ้าง
ผู้หญิงก็ถามเป็นยังไงบ้างนักเรียนเป็น
ยังไงบ้างคะ
ไม่เคยก็บอกก็โอเค
สบายดีจ้าไม่ดี
น้องก็ไม่รู้ว่าว่าคันตานะคะนักเรียนอยู่
ประเทศอะไรกันบ้างก็ไม่รู้ว่าที่ประเทศ
นักเรียนเป็นยังไงเพราะว่าที่ประเทศไทย
ตอนนี้ก็คือ
บางวันฝนตก
บางวัน
ร้องร้อนมากๆให้
ตัวอย่างเช่นวันนี้
เป็นยังไงคะวันนี้เนี่ยวันที่
11 ใช่ไหมคะเดือนตุลาคม 5 วันที่ 11
ตุลาคม
วันนี้เนี่ยฝนตกไหมคะผู้หญิงที่กรุงเทพฯ
งีบมีเวลาหู 5 ตอนเช้าน้องก็ตื่นมาก็
ประมาณ 9 โมงแล้วกันประมาณน็อค 9:00 นถึง
ประมาณอ่า
01:00 น
09:00 นถึง 13:00 นเนี่ย
เห็นฉันไป
09:00 นถึง 13:00 นเป็นยังไง
ฝนไม่มีฝนไม่ตกเอา
มากๆแต่ตอนนี้สมัยตอนนี้เนี่ยพี่เวลาที่
เราอาจเนี่ยมันประมาณแต่
04:00 นเนาะ 4 โมงเย็นเนี่ย
ดูแล้วเหมือนเหมือนๆฝนจะตกเหมือนฝนตกเหรอ
คะ
เป็นยังไงเหมือนฝนตก
มีเมฆเยอะๆอุ้ยมีก้อนเมฆก้อนเมฆก้อนเมฆ
อ้อนแม่ก้อนเมฆเยอะๆแล้วก็แบบเวลาเห็น
เวลาเห็นอากาศใช่ไหมเดี๋ยวร้อนแล้วก็
เปลี่ยนฝนตกแล้วก็ร้อนแล้วก็ขนตกชอบไหม
ครูป๊าป๊าอากาศเปลี่ยนเปลี่ยนเปลี่ยนบ่อย
ๆไม่ชอบเลยค่ะครูหญิง
อากาศเปลี่ยนบ่อยๆเนี่ยไม่ดีรึไม่ดียังไง
ทำให้ไม่สบายนะเราจะไม่ไม่สบายใช่ไหมคะ
หมายถูกต้องหาแล้วมวยมากๆเราจะป่วยหรือ
ว่าไม่สบายเป็นอะไรถ้าเดี๋ยวก็ฝนตกแล้วก็
เปลี่ยนร้อนแล้วก็ฝนตกแล้วก็เปลี่ยนร้อน
เราจะไม่สบายเป็นอะไรเราบอกว่าเป็นหมวด
หือเป็นหวัดสว่างอ่าเวลาที่เป็นหวัดอ่ะ
แล้วเราจะมีอาการยังไงอ่ะกูฟ้าหรือเรา
เป็นหวัดเวลาเป็นหวัดนะเราสามารถเช็คตัว
เองได้ง่ายๆน้องคือเราจะเริ่มมีน้ำมูกค่ะ
ๆขี้มูกนักเรียนน้ำมูกขี้มูกก็คือ
[เพลง]
วัดก่อนไกล
นักเรียนบอกว่าโอ้ย
อาโกก็จะมีทิชชู่ทำไมต้องคอยเช็ดเช็ดน้ำ
มูกหรือว่าจะเอาใช่ค่ะราคาเอาทิชชูเนี่ย
ม้วนๆแล้วก็ใส่เอาไว้เพราะว่านำวงเนี่ย
มันจะไหลจะไม่นั้นอยู่ที่นี่มันจะไหลหลาย
ๆตลอดเวลา
เรา
ก็ต้องเช็ดใช่มั้ยเช็ดเช็ดแล้วก็กระดาษนะ
ใช่ไหมคะไม่ใช่ๆ
แล้วก็ขี้เกียจไงขี้เกียจแบบว่าน้ำพูด
อะไรว่ะ
บ่อยๆใช่ไหมเราก็เลยเอากระดาษทิชชู่เนี่ย
มวลแล้วก็ใส่ใส่
สบายด้วยคนตายเลยอ่ะ
ไม่แล้ว
ลูกมันก็จะเริ่มจากมีน้ำมูกใช้เวลาที่เรา
จะเป็นหวัดอาการแล้วก็จะมีน้ำมูกนอนไหล
จากขอเพลง
ชายส่วนใหญ่นะคะคนก็จะเป็นน้ำมูกแล้วก็
จะเริ่มเก็บคอ
ข้อนะหรออ๋อเจ็บคอคอเออแมะเจ็บคอ
ก็เพื่อ
เวลาดื่มน้ำทั่วไปก็
เออหรือไม่ต้องดื่มน้ำก็ได้เนาะในปากเรา
เนี่ยมีน้ำลายแล้วอะไรแบบ
กลืนน้ำลายไหนก็แบบโอ๊ย
เจ็บคอมีน้ำมูกแล้วก็จะคิดรักหรือว่าเรา
เป็นหวัดและบางคน I
ใช่ส่วนใหญ่เวลาที่เจ็บคอแล้วก็มีน้ำมูก
เนี่ยน้ำมูกบางครั้งเนี่ยมันก็ไหลแล้วก็
ก็พอแล้วก็จะรู้สึกเหมือนแบบเราจะบอกว่า
คันคอ Smile ข้างในมันรู้สึกเหมือนถ้าเรา
มีแขนใช่ไหมแล้วเราคันเราก็จะเก่า
เสียงไวรัสเก่า
เก่าได้ใช่ไหมหรือว่าหัวแล้วก็เกาคันหัว
แล้วก็เก่าๆว่าเก่านะอ่าแต่คอเนี่ยมัน
อยู่ข้างในเวลาที่เราคันคอเราเอามือเข้า
ไปเก่าได้ไหมคะ
เอาปากกา
ไปได้ไงเราก็เลยไอใช่มั้ย
ไปจริงๆ
ใช่ไหมให้รู้สึกเหมือนเราเวลาเราอาย
เหมือนเราเก่าด้วยเหมือนเราเก่าให้มันหาย
คัน
ก็เลยๆใช่ไหมแล้วมึง
น้าบางทีอ่ะคะอันนี้คือบางคุณจะคิดวิเป็น
หวัด
เฉพาะเริ่มมีน้ำมูกเจ็บคอ
คันคอไอหรือว่าบางคนก็ตัวร้อนด้วยไหมตัว
คุณก็ตัวรองนะคือเอามือแตะก็โห 100 องศา
เซลเซียสเลยตายเถอะค่ะ
เสียก็น่าจะประมาณเท่าไหร่คะตัวร้อน 38
นะ
38  39 รัก 38 หรือว่า 39 องศาเซลเซียส
เราไม่รู้หรอกว่าจริงๆมันเท่าไหร่จะไม่
ว่าเราจะเอามือเนี่ยจับคนอะไรแตะที่หน้า
ผากเนาะนะคือหน้าผากแล้วก็จะเอามือแตะที่
หน้าฝากเรารู้สึกว่าอุ้ยเราตัวร้อนน่ะ
เราไม่สบายแน่เลยหรือว่ามันคะพี่จับอะไร
มั้ยอะรักแร้
แล้วก็มีไว้เพื่อเช็คว่าเราตัวร้อนหรือ
เปล่าใช่ไหมแอนก็เนี่ยเขาจะมีอะไรนะ
เทอร์โมมิเตอร์
เอาไว้วัดไข้หรอเหมือนตลอดอ่ะนะมันปรอท
วัดไข้ตลอดยอดเสียบแล้วก็โอ้ร้อนไหมไม่
รู้ว่ากลุ่มต้มไว้ใต้ลิ้น
เพราะบางคนนี้มันก็จะเป็นอาการของคนเป็น
หวัดหรือว่าเราแบบเรารู้สึกนิดหน่อยว่ามี
น้ำมูกเจ็บคอคอคันคอ
ไอนะตัวร้อนตัวร้อนเนี่ยก็เริ่มแบบมีไข้
เนาะภาษาไทยจะบอกว่ามีไข้เวลาที่เราณ
วัฒน์เอามือจับหน้าผากและผู้ใหญ่เราจะจับ
หน้าผากก่อนที่หน้าผากของเราเนี่ยเพราะ
ว่าปกติถ้าอยากผู้หญิงจับมันก็จะอุ่นๆไม่
ร้อนอุ่นๆๆแต่ถ้าไปจอดแล้วสิบ่ฮู้ร้อนมาก
ๆเราก็จะคิดถ้าเราเนี่ย 38 ว่า 39 ก็แปล
ว่าเรามีไข้ไม่มีไข้เนี่ยะตัวร้อน
[เพลง]
ปวดหัวไหมคะเวลาที่เราเป็นหวัดเนี่ยมันจะ
มีอาการแบบปวดหัวไหมอ่ะโอ๋มีค่ะกวนหัว
ปวดหัว
งูใช่ไหมมันก็จะมีอาการบอกปวดหัว
ปวดหัวตัวร้อนมีไข้มีไข้
มีน้ำมูกเจ็บคอ
ไอนะเจ้ามาตามแวะจาก
ที่ 3 ต้องเป็นไม่รู้ว่าแพ้อากาศหรือ
เปล่านะใจต้องเช็คดีๆถ้านักเรียนหนักแค่
แบบไปเดินไปสมมติฝนตกแล้วเรากำลังจะถึง
บ้านแล้วแล้วฝนตกนิดหน่อยให้เราวิ่งแล้ว
ตัวเราเปียกฝนไม่มีฝนฝนฝนที่ตัวแล้วเรา
รู้นั่งไปสักพักนึงแล้วแบบ
สมัยถ้าจากมันก็อาจจะไม่แน่ใจว่าเป็นหวัด
หรือเปล่าไหนจะจามแล้วก็มีน้ำมูกเจ็บคอ
เจ็บคอแล้วก็มีน้ำมูกถ้ามันมาคู่กันนะ
เป็นหวัดแน่ๆแน่นอนงานเลี้ยงจ่ายค่ะแต่
ถ้าตัวร้อนด้วยก็คือคือมีไข้ด้วยแล้วนิ
เราต้องไปโรงพยาบาลไหมว่าเราไม่สบายไง
เราไม่สบายหรอกจะไปเราเป็นหวัดเนี่ย
เราต้องไปไม่รู้หมอพยาบาลปีเออพี่เปิดโรง
พยาบาล
ถ้าเป็นครูฟ้าในกูก็จะกินยาค่ะพืชกินยา
นานแล้วก็จริงมันก็มีหลายอันนี้ไข่อากู๋
ฟ้านะคะพาราเซตามอลเม็ด
พื้นพาราหรือ pizza
หลักไม่ต้องอันนี้ใช่เล็กๆอย่า
อย่า
อย่าลดไข้หรือเปล่ายาแก้หวัดยาแก้หวัดให้
เออนั่นแหละพาราเซตามอลใช้รีนอนสาร่า
นะแต่ว่าบางทีเนี่ยถ้าเกิดกินยากินยากิน
ยาแล้วไม่หายไม่ดีขึ้นก็ต้องไปโรงพยาบาล
แล้วต้องไปไปหาหมอใช่ไหมคะก็ต้องไปหาหมอ
ที่โรงพยาบาลพ่อไปหาหมอที่โรงพยาบาลเนี่ย
คุณหมอทำไมคุณหมอ
คุณหมอ
สวัสดีค่ะ
หมอเนาะพยาบาลคุณหมอใช่ไหมคุณหมอเนี่ยเขา
ก็จะมีคำถามสวัสดีค่ะเป็นอะไรมาคะพอดีว่า
คิดว่าคิดว่าน่าจะเป็นหวัดนะคะขอเป็นหวัด
แล้วมีอาการอะไรบ้าง
ก็มีเจ็บคอเจ็บคอก็มี I  I  Mean
มีรูป
หรือว่าขี้มูกอ่ะโอ้โหแล้วก็มีมีปวดหัว
ค่ะ
มีไข้ค่ะมีไข้ก็คือตัวร้อนใช่มั้ยอ๋อใช่ๆ
ค่ะเพราะว่าพยาบาลบอกแล้วคุณเนี่ย
อุณหภูมิเนี่ยนะคะเช็คหนักเทอร์โมมิเตอร์
แล้ว
44 องศาเซลเซียสน่าจะตาย
อุณหภูมิหรือมาคุยคุณบอกเว็บ
เป็นไข้มากเป็นไข้มากี่วันแล้วคะเป็นไข้
มา 3 วันแล้วค่ะ 3 วันแล้วไม่ดีกินยาแล้ว
ใช่ไหมคะกินยากินยาแล้วค่ะไม่โอเค
เดี๋ยวขอหมอดูคอหน่อยได้ไหมคะไอเยอะไหม
ขอไอนี่ไอเยอะไหมคะ
i  i  love ขอไอเยอะแล้วนะกินยาแก้ไอไหม
คะที่เป็นยาน้ำเวลาที่ไอแล้วก็
ยาแก้ไอยังไม่ได้กินต่อทำไมไม่กินคะทำ
ค่าย
โอเคค่ะเดี๋ยวขอหมอดูคอหน่อยนะคะอะไรดูคน
ไทยไม่ใช่ค่ะดูข้างในค่ะใช้นอกไม่ดูค่ะคน
ไข้ไอ
แล้วก็เจ็บคอหมอจะดูว่าคอข้างในเนี่ยมีสี
แดงมีสีแดงไหมเธอจะได้ให้ยาเข้าตรวจตา
ด้วยโอโห้ปวดตาด้วยตาเนี่ยรู้สึกร้อนๆไหม
คะที่ตาร้อนหามันมีคนแบบไปเช๊คหน้า
ร้อนตามากอาจจะเป็น 2 อย่างนะคะก็คือเป็น
หวัดแล้วก็อาจจะมีเอ่ออะไรจี้ภูมิแพ้เนาะ
ที่จมูกด้วยโอเคเดี๋ยวคุณหมอเขียนยาให้นะ
คะอ่านี่ค่ะแล้วก็นอนเยอะๆดื่มน้ำอุ่นนะ
คะน้ำอุ่นคืออะไรอ่ะหุ่น
น้ำเย็น
น้ำแล้วก็มีน้ำแข็งน้ำแข็งน้ำแข็งน้ำแข็ง
อันนี้น้ำเย็นแต่ถ้าน้ำแล้วก็ 100 องศา
เซลเซียสอันนี้น้ำร้อน
น้ำอุ่นเนี่ยก็คืออยู่ตรงกลางค่ะ
50% น้ำเย็น 50% น้ำร้อนก็จะเป็นน้ำอุ่น
ดื่มน้ำเย็นก็คอไม่โอเคถ้ามันเย็นดื่มน้ำ
ร้อนก็ไม่โอเคมันร้อนเดี๋ยวคอจะเป็นสีแดง
มากๆดื่มน้ำอุ่นนะคะน้ำอุ่นอาจจะประมาณ
เนี่ย
50 ใช่ไหมคะสิกู 50 อะเยอะไปแล้ว
ซัก 40 องศาเซลเซียสน้ำอุ่นนะคะไม่ต้อง
ดื่ม not สิเรามีแก้วน้ำอุ่นแล้วก็
เอาสุดเจ็บคอไอเกาะจิตนิดหน่อยนิดหน่อย
นิดหน่อยเนาะให้คอเนี่ยมันมีน้ำนะคะจะได้
จะได้พูดได้อีกน้ำใช่ฮะจิบๆน้ำนึกว่าดี
ดื่มก็ได้ค่ะดื่มน้ำเยอะๆก็ดีแต่ว่าห้าม
อย่าดื่มน้ำเย็นนะคะน้ำเย็นหรือว่าน้ำ
ร้อนเพราะว่าคนไข้เจ็บแต่พอ
ใช้ต้องเป็นอิฐนี่เองขอบคุณคุณหมอมากนะคะ
ถ้า
ขอให้หายเร็วๆนะคะ
ขอบคุณค่ะที่หลัง 2 วันแล้วยังตัวร้อน
อยู่มาโรงพยาบาลนะคะระวังช็อกเพราะว่าไข้
สูงมาก 39  3 ต้องรีบมาโรงพยาบาล
ขาดรีบมานะคะได้ค่ะคุณหมอ
ที่หลังเนี่ยจะได้หยิบมาโรงพยาบาลนะคะค่า
นี่ก็คือเป็นวาดร้องอัตราบอกว่าเวลาที่
อากาศเดี๋ยวร้อนเดี๋ยวฝนตกอากาศเนี่ย
เปลี่ยนเนาะเราเนี่ยบางทีเดียวร้อนแล้วก็
ฝนตกหนาวร้อนใช่ไหมร่างกายมันแบบงงไม่อ่า
ใส่กล้องไม่สบายใช่ไหมเป็นหวัดอยู่คนไหน
จะให้นอนเยอะๆไปหาเราก็ต้องดูอาการไม่ได้
ทั้งอะอากาศร้อนอากาศหนาวแต่อาการเนี่ยก็
คือ
ออกอาการเจ็บบ่
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
เจ็บคอใช่ไหมที่คอย
เจ็บคอมีน้ำมูกนกมีน้ำมูก
ไอ
ตัวร้อนหรือใช่ไหมตัวร้อนอ๊อฟกวนหัว
ปวดหัวละแล้วก็ปวดตาด้วยใช่ไหมที่ตาในก็
บอกมันปวดอานั่นแหละนี่คืออาการของคนไม่
สบาย
ถ้าเป็นหวัดแล้วก็มีไข้นะคะทรายว่าช่วง
นี้ประเทศไทยก็ฤดูฝนนอนหลับบ้านนักเรียน
จะเป็นฤดูหนาวก็ไปนักเรียนดูแลสุขภาพให้
แข็งแรง
ๆก็ดูแลตัวเองกันดีๆนะคะคุณครูก็จะดูแล
ตัวเองให้ดีนะใส่ค่ะว่าถ้าเราเป็นหวัด
แล้วก็เจ็บคอเนี่ยเราพูดไม่ได้มันจะเสียง
แหบ
เจ็บ
ไปน้องเทียนก็ฟังไม่เข้าใจแล้วก็เจ็บคอ
แล้วก็เสียงไม่มีเสียงแบบได้
ก็ต้องแข็งแรงจะได้มาเจอกับเรา 2 คนทุกๆ
วีดีโอเลยนะคะเพลงนี้วันนี้เราสองคนก็ไป
ก่อนนะคะก่อนไปก็อย่าลืมเท่าไรคะอย่าลืม
กด Like ขอแชร์กด Subscribe ด้วยนะคะนัก
เรียนทำไมต้องกระเสมคะพูดดังๆไม่ได้เหรอ
คะติดคอค่ะ
แล้วเดี๋ยวเจอกันวีดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะ
บ๊ายบาย